I'm going off of the Kisquale prescription and starting mistletoe and B17.
The band did help the brass get better and color back so I know the hormone purpose of it helped in one way.
The other thing I'm going off of it should I start doing or another supplement to stop the hormonal feeding.
Okay so I think there's a misunderstanding of what Kisquale does because if you went and looked up Kisquale it is not an aromatase inhibitor.
So it is for her to positive breast cancer but it blocks a different pathway what's called the CDK pathway.
So it's called a CDK inhibitor. It's not an aromatase inhibitor.
So most people that are on Kisquale are also on an aromatase inhibitor and most people that are following their oncologists' suggestions are taking a medically prescribed aromatase inhibitor.
Not dim or aromaclear or something they're taking the drug that is the aromatase inhibitor.
So if let's say I was on dim or some natural aromatase inhibitor which again is going to do equally to what the drug will just shut off all astrogens.
And then I was going to do Kisquale. I wouldn't go off the aromatase inhibitor either the drug or dim because Kisquale isn't taking the place of a natural or medically prescribed aromatase inhibitor.
The answer to the question yes I would go back on dim if that's what you were using for your aromatase inhibite.
Definitely I would go back on that.